hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 1957 USSR
championship
this was played on February 21st between
McHale tall on the white end and
Alexander Tolus
okay with this one we have a pretty
one-sided attack to defeat this king's
Indian defense
a big reason for this is the structure
white will soon work with a superior one
we're going to have a space Advantage
for white a fixed Center
that will be further fixed because of a
decision by black on move nine not a
good idea to further fix the position
from that point on it becomes very
difficult even to make suggestions for
black a lot of nothing moves passing
moves in a way back and forth moves
it is almost as if in this game black is
operating on only two ranks seven and
eight
not a whole lot of space and there's
also this very narrow path of
possibilities for black maybe along the
A and B files
what I haven't highlighted yet this area
here is in a way tall's playground in
this game
so right out of the gates we could get a
sense of the space difference in the
game where the white pieces will mostly
be moving to and what the black pieces
are doing
there's two pieces to pay special
attention to in this game the king side
miners for me at least paying close
attention to these two has helped make
this game more memorable
they have something in common
they both carry a concealed threat
it may seem like why are they going to
that square what can they possibly do
from that point well watch how they
spring to life watch how they play a
significant role in this King side
attack
what is White's weapon of choice to
defeat the king's Indian defense
the zaimish with F3
let's get some more development in
this Arrangement here Queen and Bishop
battery very common
useful strategy to try and exchange dark
Square Bishops getting rid of this key
King side Defender will make a king a
successful kingside attack much more
likely
okay
castles D5 met with
C5 further fixing the position so this
is where you'll see a significant shift
in the evaluation with this ninth move
C5
what is being suggested in this position
well computer suggests H six and after
the bishop falls back to open the
position a little bit more we're now
working with an open C file and there's
a little bit more maneuvering space for
black to seek counter play on The Queen
side
in this game though it's C5 I should
also note
the Tactical Point behind H6 if white
takes on this Square this is a trick
that black has up his sleeve Knight
takes E4 hitting the queen and opening
up a square for the queen on H4
how would this play out Knight takes
Knight
land a check that's a fork
and this is how black gets the piece
back you could carry it out a little bit
further and say wait a second white in
the end could win this Pawn white is up
a piece after the Smoke Clears but white
actually black has compensation here and
this is the big compensation a very
strong piece
also stops this Rook from even
participating okay compensation for
black in a variation like this
Black's decision is C5 locked Center
Where Do We Go From Here we play on the
wings
this G Pawn is the G Knight's friend
in this game for sure
A6 Knight G3
rookie eight it's not an open file this
is more about opening up a square for a
night
in comes H4 very thematic trying to bite
at the G Pawn
so that the Rook has some play Queen A5
Bishop H6 Knight f8
H5 Queen C5 so we're seeing this
you know these nothing type moves
Bishop D3 B5 Queen side Castle so after
this next decision the capture on C4
this was really the main takeaway for me
in this game this next decision by tall
he doesn't recapture the pawn he goes
back to B1
why isn't he capturing the pawn well if
there's a Pawn on this Square
you know there's not going to ever be a
black piece on that square
if there's a Pawn on this square there's
also never going to be a black piece on
the C5 Square either
what am I talking about well if the
bishop recaptures you could maybe see a
position where the Rook gets to be for
or maybe even the queen gets to B4 the
bishop is scared away let's say it goes
here and then the pawn can advance and
who knows maybe one of these Knights
can maybe make use of the C5 Square
he's kind of with this decision Bishop
B1 saying I want to put my Bishop on a
secure Square
I'm going to let you be up the pawn
and I know now that I don't have to deal
with any pieces on these two squares C4
and C5
also if you're wondering why B1 instead
of
the C2 Square the queen
has Direct
site of B2 in case there is a battery
formed here white is already there
defending so the bishop simply goes all
the way back on B1 and for the moment
it is just staring at a pawn
not always going to be the case though
all right from here Bishop goes to h8
Rook D to G1 you see what's happening
next I said the G Pawn is the G Knights
friend in this game there we go
if this Knight is captured we know
what's happening we're taking towards
the center and not only this Rook but
really all major pieces will flood the
black king side the G file
um
get ready for for something like this if
black is capturing okay you get the
piece right back and good luck trying to
defend this you can't
so now black is in this pickle it's like
well
do I work around the night or do I take
the night and deal with these three
you have to try and work around the
night what other options do you have and
look at again as mentioned at the start
how narrow this path is for maybe some
activity against the king but there's
just no attack
there this is again a very one-sided
game with this idea the king Knight
getting into that F5 Square glued in
really with these two pawns and The Rook
there as backup
okay
what's what's this guy doing
what are what are any of these pieces
doing
this is this is maybe the best piece but
it's not coordinated
okay from here night night six to D7
Bishop G5 is opening up the H6 Square
for the Knight
Bishop G7 is played to stop the knight
from getting there and we have Knight
takes Bishop this seemed a little bit
awkward to me to see this decision like
giving up a dark Square Bishop for a
night seems crazy but
what are your Alternatives I had a look
at a passing move like A5 or queen here
or Bishop here or the Knight even
returning all of those moves
let's just put one of them on all of
those moves can be met with Knight H6
and it's kind of like
this bishop is
a captured piece what is it even doing
in the corner
very difficult position here for black
so this is this sort of uh position
black doesn't want to be in with the
bishop stuck in the corner not
contributing so
simply plays Bishop G7 Knight takes
Bishop is in there and we give a check
and try and open the position further
try and break down the dark squares
e takes F hits White's recapturing
moving forward
Queen goes back home positions opening
up on the king side Queen is hit she
goes to H2 we got this battery here look
at the major pieces
the difference with the major pieces
here
wow
how to defend this Knight E5
Bishop F4 there's a small window here
for black to get back in the game
surprisingly enough
I should also have mentioned that this
break going back here with F4
you have to weigh this very carefully
because on one hand you you break down
the pawns that are on dark squares and
this is normally good news for the
unopposed dark Square Bishop but notice
this square that has opened up for
multiple black pieces
okay it's still a an effective plan here
for white but something to consider here
playing as white that particular Pawn
break
white has this idea now to move the
bishop
he does in this position go to F4
this is where black can get back in the
ball game he doesn't find the best move
he goes with Knight to f8 Simply
defending H7 the computer says don't be
afraid of Queen takes Pawn surprisingly
enough says play Queen F6 and allow this
Pawn to be captured and maybe you could
survive this
not so easy to to play in this way
what is considered best for white in
this position instead of Bishop F4
is to come all the way back here
the idea being that Queen F6 is no
longer a good reply because you can
capture an H7 and then play to the f
file and immediately hit the queen when
the bishop was on F4 you wouldn't have
this threat
after Rook F1
okay in this game after Bishop F4 black
simply defends H7 directly
white enters on the dark squares
and after Bishop G5 you have to
play F6 if you simply move the queen
you're going to get crushed on the dark
squares
so after F6
this guy right here on B1 has been
waiting for his
uh his moment to shine well here it
comes
E5
well it's not reacting to these threats
he's ready to smash away on the light
squares so there's actually two pieces
that spring to life because of that E5
move these guys the bishop
has an open View and the Knight finally
has a square towards the king's side
from here Rook takes Pawn what other
options are there let's have a look at
the capture of the bishop how would this
play out if black captures well White's
gonna take on G6 and regardless of how
black recaptures the queen will be able
to make use of H7 or h8
let's have a look at both of them
if Knight takes Bishop you can take here
with check
go here with check these blocks aren't
doing anything you just take so the only
one to look at is the Knight block this
is now a check made in three one
two
three
and let's have a look at the other
capture on G6
and that is with the pawn
we land a check here we could go in
there
and coming up we got this check
and this is completely winning
this file will be opened up and seems
like you're going to be giving made or
winning the queen completely winning
here for white so this guy in short
after E5 is definitely poison Rook takes
Pawn follows
no one comes Bishop takes Knight
Rook B7 needs some more defense of H7
here comes the last piece
94.
what do you do here I mean in this in
this current position
white is not only
attacking for for free white is up a
piece black hasn't recaptured the piece
just yet so going for
a continuation like this you could
always just take like that and be up the
exchange
okay
in this game it is Pawn takes on G5
Rook F1 and right around the corner
there's Knight F6
so the Knight is swiped
pretty much cannot allow Knight F6 with
check that's going to collapse if you
allow that so this is what's tried Rook
takes Knight Bishop takes Rook
Rook G7
Rook F6 and Bishop takes G4 now the
continuation from here not the most
efficient there is a a very nice move
that white has in this position
the move played in the game is Rook on H
to F1 Can you spot what the best move is
here for white feel free to pause the
video
okay the very best move is leading to
some mate and eight is Bishop takes on
H7
what's the idea well after Knight takes
Bishop there's this one move that wins
quiet move Rook G6
bending the rook and also threatening
Queen takes Knight right away
this is completely winning position for
white
and the other sequence which is much
cleaner
after Bishop takes Pawn if you take what
The Rook it's a mating two
with Rook takes Knight
and queen takes Rook
okay Bishop takes H7 not spotted at this
moment
instead doubling on the f file
the Knight was attacked it's out of
danger now Rook takes D6 Queen E7 what
do we do Bishop is attacked nothing
we try to get to the back rank we just
happened to be grabbing upon on our way
to A8 so that cannot be allowed
if you take the if you take the bishop
this will be leading to mate
so black tries to hide in the corner
preparing to meet the check with the
block this is where white says
Bishop takes H seven
so now
if this guy is captured we get to the
back Rank and mate right around the
corner
okay black does not take the bishop
instead Knight B8 pretty sad move to
play
night on the
back rank there in comes the Discover
check
King G8 another check Bishop takes
Bishop Rook takes Bishop this one here
and goes no further black resigns
what are you supposed to do
can't go too far with the queen
otherwise this is going to hit so we can
test out one move
Queen D7 can be met with
Rook to H1 and what are you doing about
this
guy might as well be a captured piece
completely winning position for white
so what'd you think of this one this is
a very nice attack
by tall in this game in a fun side note
with this one a quote by
Mr Telus after the game he was he spoke
with Boris baskey also a
competitor in this event
and he said to Boris baskey quote you
know boria today I lost to a genius
what are your thoughts uh yeah I
completely agree here with uh Tal's
opponent he was for sure the magician
from Riga a genius
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video
in the comments section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign